hablemos un poco sobre los ciclos
biogeoquímicos el término biogeoquímico
suena muy elegante pero simplemente se
refiere a los ciclos que involucran a
las diferentes moléculas que son
esenciales para la vida y cómo se mueven
en un ecosistema y a través de toda la
biosfera y bueno las moléculas que nos
interesan son moléculas que incluso
pueden consistir en un solo elemento o
múltiples elementos y son moléculas de
agua h2o el oxígeno y el hidrógeno
forman parte de muchos seres vivos
forman parte de la biomasa y el agua es
una molécula muy importante para la vida
como la conocemos también tenemos el
carbono que el carbono toma muchas
formas cuando hablamos de los ciclos
biogeoquímicos pues hay dióxido de
carbono en el aire y hay un montón de
carbono en moléculas orgánicas que
forman la mayor parte de la materia como
la conocemos y bueno después tenemos
otros personajes que no
obtienen mucha atención como el
nitrógeno y el fósforo y tal vez me diga
ok ya sé que la mayoría de las moléculas
orgánicas están hechas de un montón de
carbonos y de hidrógenos y que de vez en
cuando también contienen oxígenos pero
qué pasa con el nitrógeno y el fósforo
bueno acuérdense de su adn ácido
desoxirribonucleico estamos hablando de
bases nitrogenadas nuestras a de minas y
wang y nash y todas esas cosas de las
que hablamos en el adn contiene
nitrógeno y existen otras biomoléculas
como los aminoácidos los aminoácidos
pueden formar proteínas y eso involucra
al nitrógeno mientras que el fósforo se
encuentra presente en el atp trifosfato
de adenosina o adenosín trifosfato es
muy importante en el centro de esta
biomolécula y también se encuentran en
el esqueleto del adn entonces todos
estos son elementos esenciales para la
vida
y aquí la clave es que todos se reciclan
mediante ciclos biogeoquímicos entonces
todos
todos son reciclados reciclados y
anteriormente hablamos de cómo la
energía del ecosistema fluye puede
empezar como energía luminosa
proveniente del sol y con el tiempo esa
energía se transfiere de una forma a
otra fluye de una forma a otra y es
disipada en forma de calor pero en la
materia estas moléculas son recicladas
es decir de vez en cuando caen
meteoritos pero la mayor parte de la
materia que tenemos a nuestro alrededor
se ha encontrado aquí desde la formación
de la tierra aunque primero se crearon
en reacciones de fusión adentro de las
estrellas hace miles y miles y miles de
millones de años así que toda la vida en
todo lo que hemos visto en la historia
de la tierra en su mayoría son los
mismos elementos y las mismas moléculas
que se van reciclando una y otra vez
entonces cuando pensamos en los ciclos
biogeoquímicos nos referimos a cosas
como
el h2o hablemos del ciclo del agua ciclo
el agua
tenemos un vídeo completo sobre eso pero
la versión resumida es que podemos tener
agua almacenada de diferentes formas y
un poco de eso se puede evaporar en
forma de vapor de agua que en algún
momento se condensa se forman las nubes
y después esa agua puede volver a bajar
en forma de lluvia y en todo el proceso
podemos tener animales que tienen acceso
al agua dulce y así es como forma parte
de los seres vivos e incluso existen
muchos animales que ven al agua como
parte de su ecosistema pero
profundizaremos más sobre eso en otro
vídeo ahora también puede que hayan
escuchado hablar del ciclo del carbono
ciclo
del carbón y sólo como un repaso general
del ciclo del carbono supongamos que
este es el suelo y aquí tenemos una
planta que se conoce como un productor
primario o un auto trophy hablamos de
eso en el vídeo de ecosistemas voy a
dibujar una hoja por aquí esta es una
planta en crecimiento y lo que hace
mientras toma energía luminosa toma
energía luminosa proveniente del sol y
usa esa energía para fijar el carbono el
carbono es lo que le da la estructura a
esta planta y no aparece de la nada es
reciclado en este caso lo obtiene de las
moléculas de carbono que hay en el aire
y el carbono presente en el aire se
encuentra en la forma molecular de
dióxido de carbono esto es co2 entonces
la planta usa la energía luminosa y el
co2 gaseoso con lo que puede fijar el
carbono para construirse parece que la
planta solo está creciendo y no
tenemos muy claro de dónde viene toda
esa materia pero literalmente proviene
del aire claro además de lo que obtiene
de los nutrientes del suelo
especialmente nitrógeno y fósforo eso es
lo que estudiamos con el ciclo del
nitrógeno y del fósforo pero bueno una
vez que las plantas fijan todo este
carbono un poco de eso es almacenado en
la biomasa y cuando la planta muere y
queda enterrada con suficiente presión y
tiempo se puede transformar en
hidrocarburos entonces cuando le ponen
combustible a su auto lo que en realidad
le ponemos es la energía almacenada por
las plantas que murieron hace mucho
tiempo quedaron enterradas y se
redujeron a eso pero bueno fue mediante
la fotosíntesis que las plantas
almacenaron esa energía y después
tenemos a los animales que se comen
estas plantas voy a dibujar un animal
que se la come bueno esto aparece algo
que come más que plantas parece un
cocodrilo pollo
no ustedes me entienden y cuando se come
esa planta use el carbono que
originalmente fue fijado por la planta
en su propia biomasa pero también
conforme la digiere usará la energía
almacenada en esos enlaces químicos para
vivir crecer y moverse y conforme hace
eso exhala co2
entonces el co2 regresa al ambiente y
esta es una enorme simplificación del
ciclo del carbono pero esa es la idea
general y bueno en algún momento este
ser morirá o será comido por otro y
entonces empezará la descomposición
descomponedores con lo que en el futuro
se podrá hacer uso de esos enlaces
químicos que el productor primario creó
usando esa energía luminosa y también
conforme se descompone se libera más co2
que en algún momento será fijado de
nuevo por un productor primario y bueno
también existen ciclos similares para el
nitrógeno y él
foro generalmente involucran bacterias
para fijar el nitrógeno y el fósforo
para que se encuentren disponibles como
nutrientes en el suelo para los
productores primarios que mencionamos en
el ciclo del carbono
ahora el nitrógeno no tiene mucha
atención pero este es el gas más común
en nuestra atmósfera se encuentra a
nuestro alrededor ahora mismo aún cuando
estamos respirando respiramos mucho
nitrógeno aunque no juega un papel tan
importante como el oxígeno y el oxígeno
del aire es oxígeno molecular o dos y
exhalamos dióxido de carbono entonces
podemos escribir co2 co2 ok
espero que esto les dé una noción de
cómo se recicla la materia la energía
fluye a través de los ecosistemas
incluyendo al ecosistema más grande en
la tierra la biosfera y tenemos materia
que constantemente es reciclada y a los
ciclos de toda esa materia
se les conoce como ciclos biogeoquímicos